the question that Kevin Harlan posed is
this the dagger took a while to get
answered but the answer to did and Kevin
Harlan is gonna have to call another
program great call Kevin thank you rich
thank you very much fun game to do nice
to be a part of something so historic
first walk-off Game seven buzzer-beating
shot I found out about 4:00 this morning
so it was a lot of a lot of fun to be a
well I mean to to weights I mean what
was that in the arena it sounded like
there was no breath being drawn while
the ball was flat rim absurd that's a
great way to describe it and you know
first of all we know the Leonard's story
we don't know if he's going to go back
to Toronto they would give anything to
have him back he was traded there but
more for just the one year and let him
kind of look at the landscape and figure
out what he wants to do they can pay him
50 million more than any other team so
financially it would behoove him to stay
there but that's the ongoing subplot to
their march here in the playoffs so he
has this monster game he's taken almost
not quite but almost half the shots of
the Toronto team last night down he had
taken like 32 shots in the team had
taken 70 overall so he had just put up
one shot after another and was scoring
and there was nothing Philadelphia could
do so the game was tied so they had
nothing really to lose and you saw the
rotation of them beat over there
the initial defense of Simmons the
falling out of bounds falling down and
the great thing about working at TNT is
we've got such great guys that they are
able to kind of reel in to do the
extended games we have so many playoff
games so last night our director was
rich Russo from Fox rich Russo is
directed about five Super Bowls and we
had this great sound guy in our truck
Jeff Walker and he paid particular
attention as you could tell you could
hear the bouncing ball on the rim
and with the hush of the crowd the drama
that was right the forests the sound guy
did his job the shots by rich were there
and it all kind of fell into place and I
thought Greg Anthony was terrific and
kind of taken us down the stretch so the
noise that was not heard was about the
largest most resounding noise of the
night because it did play every it was
like a movie kind of you know it was I
know I know like it really really came
together well this slow motion of the
ball on the rim actually being in real
time of motion it did seem like a movie
and then I think Kevin Harlan here in
the Rich Eisen show you do hit on the
drama of it it's not just any shot what
was hanging on that RIM and bouncing on
that rim four times it is the Leonard
story that if it didn't drop in the
Sixers won in overtime would that have
been his last game there and the fact
that it did drop now what happens with
the Sixers I mean that was hanging on
that RIM for so long Kevin on but you
cannot make it up no you can't it's hard
to even believe watching it again that
it actually happened in Philadelphia is
kind of the same story subplot with a
couple of their big players too Tobias
Harris and Jimmy Butler because they're
now free to go and they were thinking a
win there they get to the Eastern
Conference Finals they can sell Butler
on finishing his career there at the
long-term contract and so now you've got
you know two teams entering this game
seven with not just the importance of a
game seven the two sweetest words in all
of sports but you've got the reaching
consequences the long reach of what
happens in this series that could affect
what happens this summer and beyond and
you know what what does Philadelphia do
with their coach do they resign these
free agents if Toronto loses you know
Nick nurses in his first year they fired
the coach of the year last year Dwayne
Casey
thinking it wasn't enough they they they
all went in they put all their chips
both these teams put all their chips in
the middle there
on this one season 1 playoffs and we saw
that it came as close as four bounces on
the rim and just by happenstance the
right bounce went to Toronto few minutes
here with Kevin Harlan of Warner media
sports Turner Sports Center Agra it's
such a changing world here on the
Richardson show and then you want to
talk about again that that you can't
make this stuff up right from the NBA
gods if you will you call that game five
in Oakland last week and here are the
Rockets having the opportunity to go up
3-2 on the Warriors with Durant out in
the same way that they went up 3-2 with
losing Chris Paul last year they fell
apart the Warriors are now in the
Rockets position going up 3-2 by losing
their star one of in Durant although
late third quarter we know Chris Paul
got hurt towards the end of that game
five last year warriors not only don't
fall apart they close it out on Houston
I mean that was remarkable to see and in
the city enriched in the city where what
back in 95 reads on jonovic said never
underestimate the heart of a champion
and that was the original championship
group dream on green klay Thompson Steph
Curry and regardless of the new entry
that Durant has been in a two-time
Finals MVP and everything he's brought
to that organization there's three guys
and sure enough here they are called
upon again you know of Durant and the
heart of a champion was as strong a beat
as you could possibly want and the irony
of it happening in that city where those
words are uttered you know what 20-some
years ago or whatever and and they came
through I was stunned after watching him
losers in Oakland I thought for sure
this is when Chris Paul this is when PJ
Tucker this is when James Harden
finally have a brand new chapter in
their character emerge because all of
them are searching
something that individually they've
never attained yet they've had
individual success but here was a chance
now to really grab the mysteries by the
throat and and put golden state without
durant and with probably some hesitation
in their mind on their heels and it was
just the opposite you saw this
incredible second-half performance by
curry the heart of a champion the team
showed that that they have got you know
a lot still there a lot of wherewithal
and it's gonna be an interesting Western
Conference Finals for sure at that
so before we send Kevin into his day
Chris asking the poll question since
he's called half of our question go for
it
okay okay Kevin the biggest surprise
from the weekend in the NBA John Beilein
going to Cleveland
she's Kauai game winner Portland's 17
point comeback win in game 7 warriors
beat the Rockets without Durant or the
Lakers higher Frank Vogel beeline would
be a very close second I just got off
the plane and saw that and I'm stunned
yeah and we did we did their game in the
end the sweet 16 I was right behind you
Kevin I was two rows behind you couldn't
believe that's the last game he ever
coached for Michigan that amazing rich I
know it I know shocking I thought he
loved the college game you know he had
some pretty significant heart surgery
last summer yep and he's a grandfather
he's a father he's a married to his wife
for decades this is a guy that looks
into a lot of things I don't know if the
college game was too much but he now
he's going into the pro game which to me
has completely different kind of layers
of stress and travel and long jet like
it's just wow I'm stunned I would say
the Rockets losing at home that's that
to me would be the biggest stunner for
me from this past week I'm shocked that
they lost that game I thought the
previous games had all been decided by
six points or less
I thought they had played him close I
thought Durant's injury and absence
opened the door for them now to really
show something maybe a whole nother
level we hadn't seen and then I never
underestimate the heart of a champion is
the thing
come out of the weekend with great calls
Kevin really enjoying it immensely and
you know speaking on behalf of my buddy
Kurt Warner I'm looking forward to
seeing you or hearing you on the Monday
Night Football booth this fall with to
you guys doing your thing
thank you very much Richie I love
working with Kurt he's a class act
you know and by the way your your draft
coverage from the combine through the
draft exceptional and I did not turn it
off I was glued and you were the reason
why I love what you guys do in NFL
Network means a ton Kevin coming from
you for sure great call great stuff
let's chat soon thank you rich thanks
Kevin Harlan for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on be our live or
download the Rich Eisen show app